ah shoot I forgot to pick up a goat
Dwight go across the hall and borrow a
goat for Mrs Wilson
pack your bags we are going to New New
Orleans
for Mardi Gras no well I mean it happens
to be Mardi Gras but that's beside the
point I believe there are people there
who could defeat this virus with voodoo
right go to your room right now
you are messing with powers you don't
understand husband but I do didn't come
with me woman
you must listen to me cause I grew up in
a voodoo family and zombieism killed my
father then brought him back to life
we don't want any more to do with that
world then I'll have to seek out these
practitioners of the dark arts on my own
hopefully they are near that place with
the good Beignets be very careful
husband and promise me one thing if you
survive you're gonna bring me back some
of them beignets
foreign
[Music]